[Music]
george is with us in monroe louisiana hi
george how are you
hey dave i'm fine thank you very much
good how can we help hey
well uh briefly i own um 25 in a house
i've been living here alone for 16 years
there's four siblings uh i'm one of the
four two will allow me to buy them out
the fourth one refuses to sell and she
says she's moving in in january she
refuses to work
uh how my question how can i prevent her
from moving in if possible at all if i
owned three quarters at the time and i
don't at this point and number two how
can i force her to sell her part to me
or is it possible to do that
i don't know a mechanism that that you
can force her to sell
you could take the situation to court
and ask the court to solve this
90 percent of the time what's going to
happen is they're going to force the
sale of the house to split the money
yeah i i assume that the judge would not
force her to sell her apartment
correct
correct
but he would he would he would force the
disillusionment of the partnership if
any one of the partners wanted it
dissolved and the only way to do the
only way to liquidate it is to sell the
house and split the money four ways
yeah that's it gets kind of complicated
my
two siblings i i have 50 000 cash to pay
them but i've got a 401k with plenty of
money but i'm not going to boil from
that nor am i going to cash it in so i
assumed that i would be able to get a
bank loan
um
i don't understand how that works in a
sale if i purchased it myself in the
sale
i'm not sure how that works
if it went up for sale
due to uh the judge's order a
court-ordered disillusionment of
partnership assets
then you could obviously be one of the
bidders at that sale
and you just go get you can just go get
a mortgage and buy the
house okay uh well i wouldn't have the
cash money but the bank had a mortgage
let me
okay well the bank would front me the
money for a uh for those for a bid on
the house right because if it's an
auction yeah if it's a cash auction yeah
you'd have to have that set up yeah
i'll set up okay okay that's what i said
so what your next step is
uh you don't need to screw around with
this one day more
uh this is obviously a toxic situation
you need to go see an attorney today
yeah i just call one today and he's
supposed to get back with me i'm just to
see what we can do i want to try to get
my
other two siblings who are in sale get
the paperwork done
and also get the paperwork done for the
fourth one she keeps changing her mind
back and forth so at least have it ready
yeah she's a manipulative game player
uh yeah well the threat to this threat
to move in is a game
yeah yeah i i probably can't stop her
from doing it it would not yeah you can
you can if you file an action
that's going to force the sale
oh okay that's the way to do it yeah do
you think she would be one of the
bidders looking to buy it
not shiny no she does she doesn't have
any money she doesn't work that's very
brief
you know she doesn't work she sold a
house in dallas five years ago for 225
000. she moved here she told you you
need to get a job and buy pay cash for a
house where she said i don't want to
work because she's been living on that
225 now she's down to 80 and she started
getting worried about it however she's
going on a 2 000 vacation here another
week
so so what i would do is talk to an
attorney and here's the way this is
probably going to go down okay um the
attorney's going to tell you that you
could file a
as a part of the as a part of the
lawsuit to keep her from living there
until the house is liquidated
because it's a toxic because it's a
toxic situation then you can go to her
and say i'm getting ready to file
this motion with the court a forced
liquidation of the house that will
simultaneously prevent you from moving
in
now
this is going to happen you're not
moving in and the house is going to be
sold would you like me to buy you out
instead
and you can force her hand on that and
then she's going to sign the deed and
you're going to enter a check and she's
going to go away